okay thank you thanks having me I
learned a lot this morning it is
afternoon already has been delightful
it's an tough act to follow bill and the
previous speaker one thing I can promise
is there will be one answer to something
that bill wants to know so that's
something which might hopefully be
helpful and it starts out with his story
when the ar5 summer puzzle maker came
out my student Kim says whoa we're on
the IPCC and I said okay fine
and this is the figure you've seen now
again and again and the question was
this is the likely range of climate
sensitivity and there are there's six
estimates down there and actually turns
out the two are from Penn State one is
Lee Bardonia at all which is Chris
forest as a senior offer water is also L
which is myself as an senior offer and
when I saw this it says hmm combination
how did I get this so we actually we
share the same puzzlement since I'm the
senior offer of this paper if you know
what we're doing more or less let me try
to explain what's going on because this
might when you dig into this and if we
plot this in a different way this might
shed light at a apparent confusion and a
real confusion and it might point to a
need to better talk and not just talk
but if you read back whether we have
communicated and how to improve the
communication so why do we care about
this we have talked about dangerous
climate change we've talked about
tipping points and fresh holes and the
issue is that you know if the climate
system is well behaved then we force it
a little bit and it comes back but if
there is some bifurcation point we don't
want to be here then you may want to
stay in the white Aryan away from the
gray area and since it is forcing that
sensitivity knowing the sensitivity is
where the scientist comes in now if we
just do as a cartoon you say this is the
sensitivity and this is the CDF of the
two examples that we have access to
because there are no hard drives this is
the CDF of the climate sensitivity by
Olson at all and belieber dhania forest
and you can see that well they differ
they use similar data to use different
models and what our gray bars are is our
best estimate of how to reach the IPCC
language so when they say 66 the
question is the likely range what is the
likely meaning of likely range and our
interpretation that we had in an group
expert dissertation exercise which
involved lots of chocolates and no red
wine was that well we take them at a
word they are well calibrated 66 to 299
and then we have here so those are the
gray bars and to our not surprised or
relieved our fur curves do not violate
the IPC but those are actually pretty
wide doors you can drive through however
many people here are not concerned about
this one their concern about the tail
and one thing I learned by hanging out
with economists is that you may want to
plot this as a survival function which
is 1 minus CDF in the log scale which is
here here's one and then you go down and
you since you have a log scale you blow
up and you expand what you care about in
the lock so this is 1 and a hundred this
is one of thousands and we stopped it
roughly one in well you know one in
10,000 roughly and the reason why we
stopped is that we use Markov chain
Monte Carlo and at some point we just
say the computer is done we could of
course go beyond here which would be a
nice exercise which we're doing right
now but it's interesting now once you
reap lot this one here you see that the
constraints here are wide and they are
very wide which means that the IPCC
current assessment is a very poor and a
deeply uncertain ambiguous or in
nineteen uncertainty constraint on
climate sensitivity and details and if
we were to ask five people about the
IPCC that have some co-authorship it's
interesting that we have very different
ways to interpret this so this is just a
way to maybe think about this and how
this works but let's dig a little bit
deeper and the reason is house is done
how do we get the combination and the
important part is that there is Paleo
climate and combination in the
way they must have gotten this is the
following that's at least our
interpretation they have asked a Roman
Olson to give him the data and then he
plotted it under they plotted this
estimate the red one it's part of the
IPCC figure and what happens is the
following if we take an improper prior
basically just elected function we get
the blue which is also uniform prior
which is from here to here and you can
see there's standard form which you have
now this assimilates instrumental data
which means we do not assimilate paleo
data but there's information from the
Paylor data if we interpret the expert
assessment of the paler data by fitting
a mixture of two normal distributions we
get this distribution which is our
subjective assessment of what the pain
information gives and you asked five
people you get five and if you ask mr.
Schmidt Nair you get a very tight one I
wouldn't take that one but if you ask
others you get a wider one and then that
combined as a prior with delighted
function measure instrumental gives you
the posterior which is one subjective
interpretation of the pain a record with
another subjective prior on nuisance
parameters artistic parameter but that's
how it's done
now you asked a very good question I
told you basically how sorters is being
made once you see the product you may
not like the sausage anymore but this is
the way the product was done and I will
send you to do papers which describe
them so the way the combination is done
is that there is a combination of Paley
on instrumental data ideally you would
have one swoop where you can't for the
heteroscedastic observation error that
is really difficult we're working on
this and so you do this by approximating
the pater data and then doing the full
assimilation by letting priors do the
work by combining prior and posterior
information so that's the climate
sensitivity and the question was before
which is very helpful is to say how fast
would we learn and the analysis was well
assumed that all the people who do paleo
studies are sitting on the hands do
nothing and have nothing to contribute
to this if you just observe no no no
insult here and we just observe what we
see
and assimilate that that's one example
this is a perfect model example where
we've no structural error and we just
say we assimilate the same as before and
this is the best estimate this is ninety
percent range and we are similar until
two thousand ten or eleven when we have
the last data and then we say what if
the real climate sensitivity is high
medium low or really low and what is the
speed at which incredible interval is
converging the dynamics of learning and
it turns out that in the next 50 years
we do learn but there isn't a perfect
learning we learn slightly slower what
is very interesting and countering truth
is the following
you learned slower for high climate
sensitivities that is counterintuitive
because you would think since high
sensitivity high signal fast learning
but the problem is if you think about
the beautiful paper by Hansen at all
where you shows the decreasing response
of the transient response versus equally
positive which is a due to defect of the
buffering in the long response time if a
weakening is the response for high
climate sensitivity so the Trenton's
signal you get at any point actually
decreases so that is the intuition why
you learn to the point here is that
we're actually a little bit in between
we might learn to some extent in the
next 50 years you know we go from here
to maybe one two thirds of this it's not
a binary thing it is convenient to have
a binary exogenous analysis of learning
it's much more difficult but the fact
the hope that we will learn the next few
decades seems very slim unless we have a
real breakthrough in the Paley analysis
like you know we've seen certain
approaches here ok so what does this
mean now
in the implications for risky decision
houses and here what I would like to end
out with our three points where we
diagnose a problem and a few suggestions
and how we react to this problem and
those problems are overconfidence
there's a interacting parameter
uncertainties and it's watch how to deal
with epistemic ethical interacts
um the first one is basically an
explanation or demonstration of a glove
and prescription rate before use and
wide range of models and of real
uncertainties what we've done here is we
look at an IPC istanbul which is see me
free istanbul and this is the red points
and the red points here are their high
resolutions arg CMS and the sample a
small range of climate sensitive of
climate sensitivities but if we run an
earth system model of limited complexity
we can actually sample provider
uncertainty and we can get simulations
that span a wider range of climate
sensitivity that are consistent with our
pdfs and they're also consistent with
the observed trend in climate so if we
filter this out what we get is the
surviving ensemble and we see that there
are simulations with models of dynamic
ocean that have an higher climate
sensitivity that passed a filter of the
observations and that have a much larger
range of the temperature trend in the
2011 to 2016 timescale so the very
simple my son would say stupid if you
kind of detail and you're concerned
about tail area vents you have a bias
which is downward that's very simple
so the prescription to use more assam
buses is clearly important it's not that
easy
because that is something which requires
some time and there's an issue about how
to deal with the downscaling need so
that's an open question the second one
related is we need hein casts and we
don't just need hein casts for the
economic models which i applaud and has
been done the silence in the other
studies we also need to test the models
we have in integrated models with
hindcast skills so what we have here is
an surface temperature and atmospheric
co2 the red dots are the observations
and there is the green one it's a dice
model and see on and the gray one is an
on of the carbon cycle model which is
open source
which we can use a full-scale
assimilation and we can see that the
uncertainties in the temperature are
significant we have credible hindcast
intervals we can do the out-of-sample
calibration if you want but we can also
do public high caste real observation
versus what we have hand casted and we
can also make projections one important
point I want to drive home here just
again to gate of my hobby horse is that
this calibration accounts for
correlations which means we have two
full joint PDF of climate sensitivity
aerosols forcing efficiency and ocean
heat uptake in other parameters which
means that we account endogenous Li for
the relationship between climate
sensitivity and the response time for
example and this means that much of the
fat tail that is there in the
equilibrium climate sensitivity of
course is cut off or shaved off to some
extent okay next one all we like to
drunkard who is looking under the
streetlight maybe maybe not these
satelli analysis was interesting and
what I think is important is to say what
how could we identify the subset of
parameters which accounts for the
highest fraction of variance in what we
care about so if you look at the dice
model we have many many model parameters
this is a study by Butler at all where
we can group this into different ones
this is the climate sensitivity which is
one of many and what we've done here is
we ran roughly 8 million evaluations
which actually we need for numeric
stability it seems to be ridiculously
large but if we do bootstrap estimate of
the errors that's what we need it also
now is we have a supercomputer so that's
easy but the point here is the following
this then allows you to showcase what
are the key uncertainties which are the
biggest circles here's climate
sensitivity here the climate damages
here's the investment rage and here
population numbers and interaction terms
we're baited the bigger the circle the
more is important is this
and the bigger to link the most
important says this allows you to end
out to determine which parameter you
really have to care about and which
interactions to have to get out which is
additional test which you do once you
have calibrated to get the a priori
parameter values out okay talking about
correlations and that's an just another
example its climate sensitivity varying
a low and sufficient and you know pretty
required gary has shown this i think ten
years ago fifteen years ago
it's not there correlations this is the
joint credible interval between climate
sensitivity and effectiveness of aerosol
scaling this is the best estimate and
this leads to this hindcast and
projection and this is with the and our
system model of eme complexity if we go
along this banana to higher climate
sensitivity we also have to move to
higher effectiveness of aerosol forcing
to account for same rankest again and
this works we don't get the perfect fit
because we are not well there was an
issue in here but you're not in the same
thing but you basically if you go to the
back of the room and you take it for
classes then they're pretty much the
same so this this works for me but even
if there's glasses if I go here and even
go further back the red one sticks out
like it like a sore thumb so if we take
if you neglect the correlation we just
walk here yes it doesn't work so account
for correlations
it's simple I'm sorry this is repetitive
but it is important good last point
before how much time five four okay
last point and here would like to slow
down a little bit
and the reason is that this may be one
of the things I learned today the most
this might be old news for you and I
should have known this but in a sense
very smart people much more than I am
much more wise can reasonably disagree
about what is the decision criteria you
should apply yes and it
turns out that if you teach decision
houses to undergrads which is actually
fun to do you start out with Bernoulli
classic paper and say well but newly
makes it easy say what can we learn
that's an epistemic question you say get
a single PDF you're done then you say
what do you value utility and then you
plug this into your model you plug in
shock you optimize define the one
strategy which maximize the expected
value utility of and you're done you
have your one strategy that's fine and
there are many decisions that I would
analyze this way very clearly however as
we discussed today there are some
decisions where we don't know which PDF
is there where we have deep uncertainty
or ambiguity or nitrogen uncertainty
basically second-order uncertainty where
we have multi PDF where we cannot
identify or agree on a single
well-defined PDF and as we have
discussed before shown with Ellsberg and
actually well before Ellsberg if you
look at an strategy where there is an
expert a an expert B that assess the
different probability of a low
performance strategy let's think about
this like climate sensitivity and here's
the expected performance of the strategy
and you have two strategies one is the
blue one and one is the red one the red
one if you were to average expert a an
expert be saying well the plus is a
smart guy and I adopt the interface and
reasoning I just average him out the
best strategy would be in terms of
expected till he would be here but of
course you pay the price of poor
performance and then some reasonable
people might choose the red the blue
strategy and they would do this by
trading on self to trade off some of the
expected performance for decreased
vulnerability to deep uncertainty so you
know this might be something now so far
I haven't decided on which side of the
fence I'm gonna go in but I can play a
game and the game is the following the
role of the analyst might be health
to analyze what are the implications of
different value judgments and then
communicate is very clearly and
hopefully in an efficient way so this is
dice
this is abatement this is climate
sensitivity this is expected utility if
you maximize expedite ility you get this
one here and if you look at D over four
different uncertain parameter this is
just a marginal projection this is
somewhat vulnerable because it performs
poorly in the high tail of climate
sensitivity how can you improve this one
here yes you can by maximizing and
weighted average of the worst case
performance and the expected value so
this is some decision rule which is has
been some foundation and you do this but
of course it comes to the cost and the
cost is that you pay some price in this
budget value so far nothing fancy
what is interesting may be is that this
increases the abatement which is maybe
not intuitive a priori but it has to do
with what are the relative sensitivities
to higher and lower climate
sensitivities that's one the second one
things we talked about the expected
value of information the value of
information as Gary said depends on what
you value and what you really want to do
and so here is the expected utility and
here is the expected silly of the worst
1% of the outcomes and so if you've no
learning and you've perfect learning
2075 then you do a little bit better if
you do learn which means the value of
information is the tiny difference
between those two curves as you give
more weight to the worst case you
initially increase the value of
information it's because you care more
but at the end when you really only care
about the worst case you don't have a
lot because the worst case you can learn
about this and you still have this as a
case and you need to hedge against this
very much and it happens in the future
so this is a paper which is a little bit
difficult to explain but the intuition
you can argue about the details but into
the main point that the value of
information it can hinge critically on
the decision criteria and that the
reason people can disagree about that it
might be useful to showcase that there's
divergence about this
this is something that we may want to
showcase a thing is a robust conclusion
okay
summarizing I think it's fair to say
that the current IPCC assessment is
interesting but it provides a poor and
argued deeply uncertain constraint of
climate sensitivity and there seems to
be a communication problem I think we
should work on that that's something I
really want to do what we we should
think about that if you produce
overconfident estimates of PDFs and you
care about a Larry estimate risks then
you underestimate them that's trivial to
see trivial intuition but it actually
matters a lot in silver eyes you can
have orders of magnitude biases in
flooding probabilities for example this
has to do with the tail area probably's
can change drastically if you shift the
PDF there are important interactions of
primary uncertainties again but what is
beyond ah is that there are numerically
quite efficient ways to identify out of
a very large multi-dimensional PDF and
the nonlinear mapping the key factors
that really drive the uncertainties in
and you can do this for different things
you care about so you can make this plot
and those plots do exist in there on my
web page for what are the directions for
climate damages for cost for utility for
other factors and so you can actually
look at the effect of different
objectives and I think that it is
helpful and behooves us to be very
careful about prescriptive statements
and that it would be interesting from my
point of view to represent what are the
effects of different decision criteria
on the recommendation this is something
that has been done by most of the people
in the audience but I think it is
helpful to expand on this and we have
the tools thank you
you